yanis à 35 ans il est porteur d'un
handicap psychique depuis bientôt six
mois il travaille à l'hôtel hi lo à à
saint leu en tant qu'agent d'entretien
et d'hygiène des locaux son premier
emploi en cdi enfin consistant à
nettoyer les lieux publics les courants
les
l'étoile est
donc enfin les bureaux et la réception
parfois je me sens bien parfois je suis
encore
mais avec elle petit à petit ça viendra
cet emploi il l'a obtenue grâce à
l'accompagnement de lezennes et moelle
bus à saint leu
cet établissement quelques 47
travailleurs handicapés a pour mission
principale l'accompagnement vers
l'autonomie et in fine et l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle des
travailleurs handicapés une des missions
des ars et l'insertion professionnelle
nous
cette mission c'est qu'on doit être
juste une étape dans la vie d'une
personne c'est à dire que les actes doit
servir de tremplin pour l'insertion
professionnelle pour certains d'autres
ne pourront pas ou peut être inséré un
milieu ordinaire donc on l'a on vise
l'autonomie et dans la vie
professionnelle et dans la vie dans la
vie sociale pour yanis on a vu que le
potentiel était là donc on l'a
positionné sur le dispositif de la mise
à disposition après seulement huit mois
en esat yanis est mis à disposition dans
l'entreprise hôtelière c'est à dire
qu'il est d'accompagner et payés par les
actes pour travailler à l'îlot le temps
nécessaire pour yanis d'aguerrir ses
compétences de prendre ses marques dans
son environnement de travail après deux
ans de mise à disposition lillois jouent
le jeu de l'insertion et emploie yanis
en cdi on est là la changer en quoi
monsieur daniel il ya deux ans en 2012
quand les hauts de saint leu s'est créé
et nous a proposé deux personnes comme
mise à disposition en tant qu'équipier
housekeeping et on a dit ok banco donc
il travaillait à
une base de 20 heures par semaine
ceci pendant deux ans et puis nous on
avait la possibilité de créer un poste
en
saint 2014 et 2015 et là il n'y a pas eu
d'hésitation la ianis s'imposer comme la
personne embauchée
pour sa soeur qui s'occupe de lui depuis
plus de cinq ans cet emploi c'est le
signe que les choses avancent pour yanis
il peut se débrouiller tout seul bon il
peut sortir
s'il veut pousser ce cri mais un petit
peu du mal mais rencontrer des gens oui
il peut aller faire les courses je
l'inscris aussi dans le sav est ceci
salle permet aussi faire les sorties
avec plusieurs personnes en dehors de
chez moi 2 les ados aussi des lillois de
connaître d'autres personnes et voilà
c'est pour ça je suis très contente
qu'il a vraiment changé quand je viens
en arrière et quand je regarde
aujourd'hui il ya une grande différence
avec elle chaque entreprise de plus de
20 salariés est soumise à l'obligation
que 6 % de sa masse salariale soit
constituée de personnes porteuses de
handicap sous peine de payer une taxe la
relation avec les esat a donné
l'occasion travailleurs handicapés de
prouver qu'ils étaient tout aussi
compétent qu'une personne valide c'est
tout naturellement que la direction de
lillois a largement dépassé cette
obligation de quotas déjà avec dîner en
2011 a été au delà des quotas et et
aujourd'hui avec à nice je pense que
demain si une autre opportunité on fera
la même chose le handicap c'est les
personnes de regard des autres mais au
quotidien dans son travail à compétences
égales soit pas pourquoi j'aurais pu
embaucher liste aucun autre connaissez
la maison et connaissez les équipes ils
étaient intégrés
100% gagnante fait c'est une vraie
réussite yanis a été inséré le
partenariat avec la famille avec
l'entreprise et toute l'équipe
pluridisciplinaire qu'on a sur les
halles de saint leu comment a pleinement
réussi quoi voilà c'est vraiment une âme
une association professionnelle à 100 %
alors que yanis est en poste son
handicap est pris en considération il
est suivi par une tutrice c'est à dire
une personne référente et son travail
est aménagé il fait son boulot quand
même comment une personne valide et
l'est pas on voit pas son handicap du
tout et il est autonome et et fait son
travail comme comme moi comme vous et
son handicap personnes voire souhaitait
quand même gardé son ton travail sur le
matin de par sa fiche de poste puisque
en tant qu'équipier aux skipping ne
travaille que le matin et ne pas trop
non plus le perturbé entre guillemets il
reste sur des axes qu'ils connaissaient
depuis deux ans pour qu'ils puissent
s'intégrer s'épanouir
avec le temps ça évoluera je pense en
fonction de basse et souhaité une aux
besoins aussi et j'aimerais bien qu'on
aille sur un contrat demain de 35 eur et
39 heures aujourd'hui yanis et
indépendant il gagne sa vie et est sa
soeur tant financièrement que dans la
vie quotidienne avec cette assise solide
il peut se projeter dans l'avenir
d'avoir à chez moi déjà plus tard et
voiture
pour avoir déplacé pour aller travailler
mais
et
grâce à une collaboration finement menée
cette insertion est une réussite pour
tous pour les actes qui accomplit sa
mission l'hôtel qui trouve un employé
fiable et yanis qui gagnent en autonomie
ici tout le monde est satisfait c'est
une réussite à 300%
oh